meanwhile the media which again they
have a vested interest in the idea that
the government solves all of your
problems they are fighting mad that
they're members of the government who
actually would like the government to
butt out of your business so right now
the republicans are considering the
possibility of pushing the democrats to
get rid of the vax mandate in order they
can pass their new debt ceiling increase
okay this is a good idea because frankly
democrats need to have their feet held
to the fighter on this the democrats
have been embracing these vax mandates
via osha they've not been forced to a
vote on it yet
and so the democrats who had like pretty
much six weeks to figure out this whole
reconciliation debt ceiling thing and
then they just didn't do it
they they waited until the last minute
again and now republicans are holding
them they're squeezing them according to
politico conservatives on both sides of
the capital are privately plotting to
force a government shutdown friday in an
effort to defund the biden
administration's vaccine mandate no no
they're not plotting to force a
government shutdown they're plotting to
force the end of the vax mandate
and biden can choose
capitalizing on a last-minute scramble
to fund the government a group of senate
conservatives is planning to object to
quick consideration of a stop gap
measure to extend funding into early
2022 unless democratic leaders agree to
deny money to enforce the mandate
because of the tight schedule and senate
rules that require unanimous consent to
move quickly the senators believe they
will be able to drag out the process
well past midnight friday when funding
officially expires
senator mike lee republican of utah full
disclosure i'm friendly with senator lee
because he's a terrific senator because
i'm sure we would all like to simplify
the process for resolving the cr but i
can't facilitate that without addressing
the vax mandates given that federal
courts across the country have raised
serious issues with these mandates it's
not unreasonable for my democratic
colleagues to delay enforcement of the
mandates for at least the length of the
continuing resolution
it's unclear how many senate
conservatives are willing to follow
through on the shutdown threat but
apparently 15 republicans have signed a
letter spearheaded by senator roger
marshall of kansas in early november
vowing to use all means at our disposal
to block passage of a continuing
resolution that doesn't stop
implementation of a vast mandate now
here's the thing if democrats had
started on the continuing resolution
three weeks ago they'd be fine they
didn't they waited until the last moment
again because democrats have no
intention of actually preventing a
government shutdown they just want to
spend all the money and rope republicans
into approving it they did this last
time republicans gave them another
another stay of execution and then mitch
mcconnell said we're not doing this
again
and democrats were like well what if we
just push it to the last minute again
the strategy according to politico means
the government will likely shut down for
several days even if appropriators
strike a bipartisan agreement to extend
funding by the end of today a senate
democratic leadership staffer told
playbook without an agreement to
truncate the timeline the senate would
need at least five days to process the
continuing resolution that would mean a
brief shutdown ending sunday at the
earliest but possibly dragging into next
week if a deal is not reached today
senator major senate majority leader
chuck schumer appeared to nod to the
possibility of trouble seeking to
preemptively blame the gop
meanwhile mitch mcconnell predicted
tuesday we won't shut down arguing quote
nobody should be concerned about a
government shutdown
the issue came up in the senate gop
launch on tuesday
so
here's the thing the democrats control
both houses of congress
so all they have to do to prevent a
government shutdown is they could
initiate the continuing resolution today
and use reconciliation use one of the
bullets in their chamber to simply pass
the continuing resolution you have a
government shutdown that lasts about 24
hours without republican approval
and they could do that or they could try
to drag this out on behalf of a vast
mandate that is increasingly unpopular
with the american public
so chuck todd of course you know which
side he's going to come down on he's
going to come down on the side of i like
i love vax mandates and i also love
democrats and so republicans are the
problem here even though democrats run
both the house and the senate here is
chuck todd over on msnbc
aren't all members of congress
folks come on members of congress aren't
you embarrassed
by the silliness of this debt limit
thing that we go through this shenanigan
just shame on all of you shame come on
particularly republicans you're playing
games this time i know the democrats
play games but enough of this this is
stupid enough of it
enough it's so stupid it's it's stupid
really because uh the democrats did it
when republicans were in office they
also negotiated over the debt ceiling
it's pretty common politics at this
point and democrats can move forward
with this any time they want but they
were the ones who decided to delay all
of this specifically so they can then
try and blame republicans for it janet
yellen the treasury secretary says oh we
have to pay our bills we have to pay our
bills oh i have an idea how you could
pay your bills you know a great way not
spending trillions more dollars all the
damn time that would be a good way to
start paying your bills
there are two decisions facing congress
that could send our economy in very
different directions
the first is the debt limit i cannot
overstate how critical it is that
congress address this issue
america must pay its bills on time and
in full if we do not we will eviscerate
our current recovery
um
so i again would recommend a little
fiscal responsibility would go a long
way here at no point has janet yellen
suggested perhaps you should spend a
little bit less money in fact janet
yellen lies she says the build back
better won't increase the national debt
despite the fact the cbo says precisely
the opposite
buildback bitter is the right economic
decision for many reasons it will for
example end the child care crisis in
this country letting parents return to
work these investments we expect will
lead to a gdp increase over the long
term without increasing the national
debt or deficit by a dollar okay
these people lie they lie they lie they
lie and then they're like oh yes by the
way we need to pay our dads they're just
liars they're just liars but here's the
thing the media continue to lie for them
continue to cover up for them these are
the normal people these are the people
who should be in control of your life
it ain't about chris cuomo it's about
all of you all of you and you know what
keep doing it because frankly we here at
the daily where we are happy to eat your
lunch as more and more people continue
to look elsewhere for better sources of
news
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe